In the last video we learned a
little bit about what a chiral
molecule or what a chiral carbon
or a chiral atom is.
What I want to do in this video
is go through a bunch of
examples and see if we can
identify if there are any
chiral atoms and to also
see if we're dealing
with a chiral molecule.
So let's look at our
examples here.
So here I have, what is this?
This is chlorocyclopentane.
So the first question is do
we have any chiral atoms?
And when we look at our
definition that we thought of
chiral atoms, it all comes from
this notion of handedness
and not being able to be
superimposable on your mirror
image, but we said that they're
usually carbons bonded
to four different groups.
Let's see, do we have any
carbons here bonded to four
different groups?
Well, all the CH2's, they're
bonded to another CH2
and then two H'2.
I could draw it like
this: H and H.
So they're bonded to two of
the same group, so none of
these CH2's are good candidates
for being a chiral
center or chiral carbon.
They're both bonded to-- or all
of them are bonded to two
hydrogens and two other very
similar-looking CH2 groups,
although you have to look
at the entire group
that it's bonded to.
But they're all definitely
bonded to two hydrogens, so
it's not four different
groups.
If we look at this CH
right here, we could
separate it out like this.
We could separate the H out like
this, and so since it's
bonded to a hydrogen.
This carbon is bonded to a
chlorine, and then it's bonded
to-- well, it's not clear when
you look at it right from the
get-go whether this group is
different than this group.
But if you go around, if you
were to split it half-way like
this, or maybe another better
way to think about is if you
were to go around this molecule
in that direction,
the counterclockwise direction,
you would encounter
a CH2 group, and then you
encounter a CH2 group, and
then you would encounter a
third, and then you would
encounter a fourth CH2 group,
then you would come back to
where you were before.
So you would encounter four
CH2's and then you'd come back
to where you were before.
If you go in this direction,
what happens?
You encounter one, two, three,
four CH2's and you come back
to where you were before.
So all of this, this bottom
group, depending on how far
you want to extend it, and this
top group, are really the
same group.
So this is not a chiral center
or not a chiral carbon.
It's not bonded to four
different groups.
And this is also not a chiral
molecule, because it does not
have a chiral center.
And to see that it's not a
chiral molecule-- let me see
if I can backtrack this
back to the way I
wrote it right before.
So you see that it's not
a chiral molecule.
There's a couple of ways you
could think about it.
The easiest way, or the way my
brain likes to think about it,
is just to think about
its mirror image.
Its mirror image will
look like this.
So if that's the mirror, you
would have a chlorine.
Then you have a CH, CH2, CH2,
and you have a CH2, CH2, and
then you complete your
cyclopentane.
Now, in this situation, is there
any way to rotate this
to get this over there?
Well, if you just took this
molecule right here and you
just rotated it 180 degrees,
what would it look like?
Well, maybe a little over--
yeah, well, not quite 180
degrees, but if you were to
rotate it so that the chlorine
goes about that far, you would
get this exact molecule.
You would get something.
It would look a little
bit different.
It would look like this.
Let me see if I can
do it justice.
It would look like this.
You would have a CH2.
So let me let me do it up
here where I have a
little bit more space.
If I were to rotate this about
that far, I would get a CH.
You get the chlorine and then
you have your CH2, and then
you have another CH2, CH2,
and then you would
have your CH2 up there.
If you were to rotate this all
the way around, or actually
this is almost exactly
180 degrees, it
would look like this.
And the only difference between
this and this is just
how we drew this bond here.
I could have easily, instead
of drawing that bond like
that, I could draw it facing
up like that, and these are
the exact same molecule.
So this molecule is
also not chiral.
So let's go to this
one over here.
So what is this?
This is a
bromochlorofluoromethane, just
to practice our naming
a little bit.
But it's very clear that
we are bonded to
four different groups.
All of the different groups, or
the atoms in this case that
are bonded to this carbon, are
different, so this carbon is a
chiral center.
And it should also be pretty
clear that it is
also a chiral molecule.
If you were to take its mirror
image, and this is very
similar to the example we did
in the first video on
chirality, but its mirror image
will look like this.
You have the bromine
on the right now.
The hydrogen is still in
back, and you have the
fluorine above it.
No matter how you try to rotate
this thing, if you try
to get the bromine all the way
over there, all the way to
that position, then the hydrogen
would be in this
position and the chlorine would
be in that position.
And no matter how you try to
flip this around or rotate it
or shift it, you will never be
able superimpose this molecule
on that molecule right there.
So that is a chiral center and
this is a chiral molecule.
And there's a word for
these two versions.
We're going to go into the
naming of them later on.
It's a little bit
more involved.
We'll have a whole separate
video on it.
But these two versions of
bromochlorofluoromethane, they
sometimes have different
chemical properties.
And these are called
enantiomers.
And enantiomers are just
the mirror images.
Each enantiomer is a mirror
image of each other, but they
are stereoisomers.
This is all just terminology.
Stereoisomers.
You're familiar with the word
isomer, and isomer just means
that you have the same atoms
in your molecule.
But then you have different
types of isomers.
You have constitutional
isomers that say, OK,
different things are connected
to different things.
Stereoisomers, the same
things are all
connected to the same things.
You have a carbon connected to
only a fluorine, a chlorine
connected to the carbon, a
hydrogen connected to the
carbon, a bromine connected
to the carbon.
So all of the same things are
connected to the same things,
but they're a three-dimensional
configuration.
That's where we're dealing
with the stereo part.
Stereochemistry is the study
of three-dimensional
chemistry, as essentially
understanding the actual
three-dimensional structure
of things.
So stereoisomers mean that we
have the same constituents,
the same atoms. They
have the same
connections to each other.
Bromine is still connected
to carbon, which is still
connected to hydrogen.
That's all true over here.
But their three-dimensional
orientation is still different.
And in this case where they
are mirror images of each
other, we call them
enantiomers.
And I should probably make
one clarification.
In the last few videos, I've
been a little bit, you know,
sometimes I'll say configuration
and sometimes I
use the word conformation.
So sometimes I'll use the word
configuration and sometimes I
use the word conformation, and
I actually should be a little
bit more, or I should have been
a little bit more exact
about these.
When you're talking about a
configuration, you're actually
talking about a different
structure.
To go from one configuration to
another configuration, you
would actually have to
break bonds and kind
of reassemble them.
So these are different
configurations.
Because in order for them to be
able to be the same thing,
you would have to swap maybe the
bromine and the hydrogen
in there where they are relative
to the carbon, so
these are different
configurations.
Confirmations are really just
different shapes or different
orientations of the
same molecule.
So when we talked about
cyclohexane being in a boat,
so this is cyclohexane being
in a boat conformation, or
this is cyclohexane being in a
chair conformation, it's the
exact same molecule with the
exact same connections.
We didn't detach any bonds
or reattach any bonds.
They just flipped around
a little bit.
So these are two different
conformations.
These are two different
configurations.
To go from one configuration
to another, you have to
rearrange bonds.
Now let's look at this
molecule over here.
Can we identify any
stereocenters or chiral
carbons or chiral atoms?
And you have this carbon
right here.
Let's see, this carbon right
here is bonded to a chlorine,
a hydrogen, a bromine, and
then another carbon.
So this is bonded to four
different things, so this is a
chiral carbon.
Sometimes they put a little
asterisk there.
If we look at this carbon right
here you can-- well,
it's bonded to a fluorine and
another carbon, but it's
bonded to two hydrogens,
so it's not chiral.
It has two of the same things
that it's bonded to.
You can even see a little axis
of symmetry through it.
If you look at that, you can
kind of flip it over, and it's
going to be the same thing.
But this one right here, that
is a chiral center.
That is a chiral center, or
chiral carbon, or chiral atom,
or a symmetric carbon.
You'll see it used in
different ways.
And because this molecule has
got that chiral center, you'll
see that if you were to take its
mirror image, it would be
an enantiomer.
This is not superimposable
on its mirror image.
We could even try to draw it.
And just so you know, you don't
always have to do the
mirror image on the
right side.
We can draw the mirror image
on the left side.
So if we want to draw
its mirror image, it
would look like this.
You would have a fluorine,
carbon, carbon, chlorine.
You have your two hydrogens,
and then you would have a
hydrogen here, and then you
would have your bromine here.
No matter what you try to do, if
you try to flip this around
or whatever, you will never be
able superimpose this on top
of this, so these
are enantiomers.
These are both stereoisomers
relative to each other.
And either of these, regardless
of which one you
pick, are chiral molecules.
I'm over the time that I
normally want to go in the
video, so in the next video
I'll do even more.